let's go to South Carolina Georgia's
neighbor that's another place where
there is a stark divide over
mask-wearing it's particularly sharp
there in fact South Carolina reported
more than 1800 new cases that was just
yesterday and who's getting the blame
tourists are getting the blame for that
increase mark Strassman is in Charleston
South Carolina where the streets are
full of visitors already mark good
morning how serious is the outbreak
there and put it this way tonot they had
to put up a sign in the heart of
downtown to remind people masks here are
mandatory
this is Upper King Street downtown
Charleston an area known for its shops
bars and restaurants southern charm and
now the zip code with the highest code
rate in all of South Carolina health
officials estimate more than one in
three residents would test positive
summer heat kovin hot spot and yet
tourists often barefaced and
shoulder-to-shoulder crowd downtown
Charleston streets you're not worried
about it no blaze and David Jorgensen
and their family left another hot spot
Phoenix to vacation in Charleston I mean
why would I be scared of it it's like
the flu you know so it's you know
everyone's gonna get infected everyone's
got it you know we're humans you know we
live through the stuff that our bodies
are designed to do
epidemiologists disagree South Carolina
has recorded more than 25,000 new cases
over the last two weeks despite the
threat governor Henry McMaster is
pushing schools to reopen in September
we must reopen our economy people must
go to work schools must have in class
face to face teaching so these children
do not fall behind by city ordinance in
downtown Charleston masking is not a
choice it's mandatory for anyone over
the age of nine the city just doubled
fines for violators $100 for the first
offense
most people we saw wore one not Melissa
Dickinson from Southern Illinois we
forgot that
yeah but you feel like think about it um
yeah I mean when we pass to public the
people we just connect another challenge
almost 140,000 American deaths into the
crisis many people see the kovetz care
has overblown
I mean people die of stuff all the time
I don't know why I would change my life
to you know be afraid of this there's
plenty of stuff to be afraid of this is
certainly not one of them I talked to
one clerk here on King Street in an
upper end clothing store she had to tell
a customer that he had to put on a mask
or leave the store
he got irate stormed out threatening to
sue the store she saw the moment before
it it probably was an idle threat Gail
we live in strange contentious times we
really do mark I don't know what more we
can say to convince people it is a
matter of life and death it's not
politics when it comes to a mouse thank
you very much mark Strassmann